what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today before we
start make sure you like the video and
subscribe to the channel as you already
know a like is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
videos so make sure you hit the like
button now um so today we are continuing
child custody Series today we have a
special guest and we wanted to speak
about your experience with the court
system and the indoctrination that's
gone on with your son so um do you want
to give you a little intro to the people
yeah my name is Harrison Kinsley I'm
finding for my son Sawyer I want nothing
more than him to be happy with who he is
and I think that all children should be
able to be happy with who they who they
are and we shouldn't be pushing any
ideology on them what got you into this
like how did this start for you into
custody or yeah well I was dating my
girlfriend at the time and shortly after
we started dating she got pregnant and
we were both happy about that fact which
is wonderful and so about halfway
through her pregnancy she has some
mental illness problems essentially kind
of a hostile environment constant
threats of me not being able to see my
son if I wasn't exactly who she wanted
me to be essentially really like what
like if I don't protest for a left-wing
cause like oh wow you won't yeah so she
was trying to what what type of
organizations
I wasn't specific it was just little
conversations and things like that or
wow transgender issues as well wow so
she was saying that if you didn't
protest or like get involved in leftist
ideology type stuff that she wouldn't
let you see your son like different
threats but yeah wow okay so what
happened next
basically she demanded that I get us
couples counseling so which I was
apprehensive at first and I finally did
because I was like I want to see my son
and then I got couples counseling she
bailed on going
did it a second time she bailed again
and after that second time I got like a
cease and desist from her attorney
basically saying like oh don't talk to
me or my family
Etc
and yeah how old was your son at this
point no this is just her being pregnant
oh we've talked about so far oh shoot so
there wasn't even a child at this point
no yeah okay so she's pregnant and then
you receive a cease and desist letter
from her
yeah probably from her attorney and
essentially I just waited a few months I
remember my son's due date but I wasn't
there for the birth which was really sad
just because I hear like these crazy
stories about people that are like Green
Berets and rock stars and they're like
oh the best day of my life is the day my
kid was born
um wow so she didn't even let you there
be there when he was born no yeah wow
because it was sad I found out like a
week later one of our friends Senate
sent me like social you weren't even
told not told at all yeah okay so you
find out you have a son then what
happens well I knew I was gonna have a
son because we'd gone to the doctor
together and stuff we agreed upon his
name Sawyer which is like the one thing
we ever agreed on which is cool
um basically I tried to figure out what
to do in that situation because that's
not something that's like common
knowledge you'd know what to do I went
to like a self-help center in San
Francisco court and they helped me file
stuff to basically establish paternity
and then try to get visitation rights
okay but it took a very long time okay
uh what was that process like
uh you file all this paperwork they help
you do it right then and there it takes
a few hours and then basically you file
it all they have a certain amount of
time to respond
if they don't respond that amount of
time you win by default which that
actually happened so I actually should
have won by default because they took so
long to respond but because of covid
what's the time period
it's usually like 60 days or something I
don't recall that exact one okay it was
different timelines for different
requests but
basically filed all the stuff they
didn't respond but it was because covet
happened right then so they got extra
time and then essentially I filed in
court two months after he was born and
it took 13 more months after that and I
didn't meet my son until he was 15
months old wow
during this time were you telling her
you wanted to see your son you wanted to
meet well I wasn't talking to her
because I wanted to avoid legal trouble
because the cease and desists letters
right so I was just
our attorneys were in communication
trying to have me see him and she just
made impossible reasons why I couldn't
with covet or different things and what
what were like the reasons she gave like
because you know they'll always say like
what's her reasoning for doing this
right well I can't speak for her but I
mean kovid was one of the excuses they
used as well as she made up false
allegations against me
that was something that happened what
type of allegations
uh she was calling me like a domestic
abuser essentially calling me the r word
wow with no truth to it at all that's
the crazy thing I've seen that so many
times in in
um
these interviews where it's like these
girls will just throw out these
accusations at guys with just so they
can't see their kids and it's crazy
because so many of you like are fighting
trying to be in your kid's life but they
keep throwing these accusations at you
yeah it happens extremely it's really
common in Family Court unfortunately I
saw like a Michigan study it was
something like 72 percent of girls make
up lives when there's a custody or 72 it
was just one Michigan study but yeah
basically the majority and I wonder if
like attorneys tell them to do this or
how and like they all feed off of it
each other or how it happens but they
suck in the UK I think the women's
shelters do like the women's because
they're very much indoctrinated with
like the leftist propaganda that's
that's my opinion were there any
consequences for her doing this not
letting you see your son for a year and
a half
the judge said it was a shame on our
first hearing but that was there was no
actual consequences no what happened
next did you get custody how did it go
so what happened is I got the right to
meet him and it actually had to be
supervised at first which was extremely
unpleasant not professionally supervised
but I would be like supervised by like
her parents or whoever and they made it
extremely uncomfortable
um
but that remember one time my sister
because I would bring my sister or Mom
with me and stuff in case they tried to
lie about me
and my sister caught her dad who like
let us go ahead one time in San
Francisco
um and he stayed back
he I want to say he smoked a cigarette
or something and then my sister caught
him like in the bushes trying to like
watch us from the bushes and she even
got pictures and we sent it to the court
and everything so it was just they made
it really uncomfortable but it was still
obviously incredible to finally meet my
son and start bonding well and why why
did they have to be supervised was it
because of the allegations well the
judge didn't buy into the allegations
that much because she's like said no to
professional ones
um she was just like just to make sure
it's someone that the kid's familiar
with to make sure it goes well basically
at least that's how they ordered it okay
no because that's what I've heard like
they'll they'll say that like the issue
with getting custody or some like in
this case visitation is that the kid's
not comfortable with you but the only
reason the kid's not comfortable with
you is because the mom hasn't let you've
seen him in a year or year and a half
whatever it is right and it doesn't seem
like there's any consequence for that
yeah not not that I know of I mean I
know that false allegations in court at
least in family court in California
can end up in a parent losing custody
that made up the false accusations wow
that's great I think it's rare but it is
a rule I mean because I I feel that I
did that exact thing on the last trial
we had and the judge kept custody the
same so what happened next okay so I
have these supervised visits and I start
getting instead of one day it would be
like two days in a row unsupervised but
not overnight and then the judge
basically hinted at during the hearing
like oh if you move to the
Bay Area because I was in Tahoe you
could perhaps get custody so I moved to
the Bay Area and I filed for custody I
actually ended up winning half custody
which was amazing wow yeah you're the
only person I've interviewed that's
gotten half custody yeah I mean maybe
that that's part of repercussions for
making stuff up or or I'm just lucky but
yeah right now I've had half custody for
well over a year it's it's been
incredible so how how far did you move
from Lake Tahoe to the Bay Area so like
four hours wow it's even four hours to
get custody of your son that's amazing
yeah that's amazing thank you is easily
worth it I would do a lot more than four
hours yeah yeah no but it's it's like we
have this narrative in the media media
men are these deadbeat dads that don't
want custody of their sons or daughters
and they don't want to be in their lives
and it's like I talked to Father after
father like you're willing to move four
hours to maybe get custody of your son
right maybe you didn't even know if you
would correct yeah I think it's a
totally false narrative I don't buy it
at all I talk to lots of fathers as well
it seems to me like they're all wanting
to be part of their kids lives and it's
so sad that a lot of them aren't I mean
like 27 percent of dads don't even get
to see their kids regardless of if
they're winning Dodd's only win custody
18 of the time as opposed to 82 for moms
and I think as a real tragedy in society
and we're seeing the effects of it like
90 of homeless people and arsonists are
from fatherless homes majority of you
know people in prison and drug addicts
and all these horribly sad things come
from fatherless homes
so I really think it's important to get
why are you being in the system like why
do you think it is like why don't men
get custody of their children
I think perhaps it's just the natural
bias says it's been that way for so long
that they just tend towards giving it to
the mother yeah that's what I think too
I don't think a lot of it's like
conscious but I think when you have
propaganda saying we don't need dads
right and that men are deadbeat abusers
for 50 years people start to buy into it
a bit Yeah sadly but I I don't think
that's a common reality it's just a
narrative no it's not the more I do this
documentary the more I think it's
literally just spiteful women
genuinely like they use the kids as
pawns like what what reason did she have
to not let you see your son
what real perhaps we disagreed
politically that's the only thing I can
think of yes okay so you didn't want to
be a feminist so now your son needs to
be at every statistical disadvantage
correct like that's that's crazy that's
the most selfish thing I've ever heard
yeah it doesn't seem like a good idea
for a child it's not it doesn't seem
like it's not yeah it's a narcissistic
thing to do for sure
um okay so you fought and you eventually
got 50 50 custody yeah so tell me what
what happened with she's trying to make
your son trans
so she's treating them as non-binary
okay
um
which is obviously not healthy for him
and I don't understand how anyone if you
love your kids so much like people do
you know when you have a kid it changes
your whole life I mean it elevates the
amount of love you knew you could feel
the amount of things you could feel like
in a way that's just
Indescribable and how you could want
someone that you love that much to not
be happy with who they are and putting
them at more statistical disadvantages
like you said like suicide and all these
things that come along with things like
that it's heartbreaking and how it
happened I'm not sure if it's
she has her own sort of gender Journey
going on as far as I know oh wait so
she's trans
so
from what I gather from social media I
don't speak to her often but um
she went from dating me to being lesbian
to now she's non-binary oh wow so I
don't know if she's pushing that onto
him or if it's something to spite me as
you were saying or what but what is
non-binary I don't I'm not with these
terms I'm not too with it either but
essentially it's just like treating them
as not a boy or a girl so that they
could choose themselves something like
that but she didn't she actually treated
him as a boy for his first like year and
a half of life I want to say so it kind
of came out of nowhere it seemed to me
um
so maybe it was from me getting custody
or I'm not sure what and how how so he
was what too when she starts treating
him as non-binary maybe a little under
but yeah too and then how old is he now
three and five months okay and is this
like does he bring this stuff to you
like the stuff she says he'll tell me
stories
um he definitely 100 knows and feels
he's a boy he'll tell you that if you
ask him and if you say anything like
that he could even conceive as possibly
calling him a girl or something like
that or giving him like a girl's toy
when he's playing with his girl cousins
he'll like get mad now and he'll be like
no I'm a boy not a girl he'll start to
yell at you because it's upsetting him
so much
and
I can tell you what he does share with
me is like like for example she took him
to Disneyland one time
go to Disneyland I assume they had fun
right and then a few months later he's
like Dada you know like he wanted to
tell me something and I knew he wanted
to tell me something because you know
you know your kids so well you know what
the situation is when they say things to
you and he was like when Mommy took me
to Disneyland I couldn't go on the rides
unless I wore my princess shoes
and I remember just being like you know
so devastated in that second but I tried
to like just be normal to him and be
like you know I'm so sorry buddy next
time you know make sure you stand up for
yourself and say I I want to go on the
rides you know I don't want to wear
those you can you can say that
but it's just heartbreaking so
heartbreaking to think like you took
someone all the way to Disneyland
assuming what he's saying is true which
I believe it is you know and then not
letting them go on the rides unless he
does something he doesn't want to do
it's just
yeah so she's pushing this gender
ideology on to him he's not even I mean
because the left is going to say oh we
let the kids choose right you're not
really letting him choose if you're
making him wear girl shoes he doesn't
want to wear
yeah and it's not just that one time I
mean there's there's been pictures that
have arose from social media people have
sent me and I've provided them to court
as well it wasn't our main source of
trying to get custody but it was one of
the things we brought up there's been
lots of pictures of him in dresses and
makeup and stuff like that he puts that
on a three-year-old yeah wow
oh so you're so you're you're trying to
raise your son and you're just scrolling
on social media or your friends are
sending you stuff friends yeah yeah and
it's basically your son dressed up as a
girl correct and there's nothing you can
do right now to stop it exactly wow the
court said that that's not something
that they would rule on
no no yeah
and it's like they're not even putting
the child's best interest at heart
because with at a three four-year-old
you're so conf like you don't know
anything about the world and now you
can't even they can't even tell you what
your gender is they don't understand an
abstract conduct of like all these
genders they just see their basic
reality in the world for what it is that
you know like I'm a boy and you're a
girl that's all you know kids like
Sawyer C is just
boys and girls and I think it's really
sad to confuse them with stuff like that
they can't comprehend that
other examples do you have of like like
times she's done this
um
sometimes when I pick them up he'll have
like a girl diaper on like Frozen
princesses which isn't like the end of
the world like maybe the store was out
at boys diapers I doubt it
but stuff like that or like a pink shirt
but she when I pick him up generally he
doesn't have anything to
you know flamboyant or whatever you want
to call it
which is good
so what's your experience been like
sharing this with the court they don't
take it into account at all the gender
stuff it doesn't appear that that the
Court's concerned with that there's
other issues that have Arisen that I've
brought to court as well but yeah the
court declined to rule on the gender
stuff because like there was a situation
like I got a restraining order on her
and one of the things I tried to include
was
um to treat him as a boy and they
declined to do that part of the
restraining order wow so there's no way
you can even legally protect your son
from her putting feminist ideology on
him well I'm gonna do everything I can
and keep fighting yeah I meant so sorry
I meant so far yeah wow
yeah it's a tough situation especially
in California is this common have you
seen this like going into this have you
seen other fathers in the same situation
I've seen other fathers in very similar
situations regarding some of like the
mental health aspects and accusations
the gender thing on a personal level I
haven't seen too much of it although you
do see stories like Jeff younger from
Texas you know and has had like twin
boys and the mom was Trans in one of the
sons in the Court ruled to continue to
do that so it's starting to happen more
and more and I see online there's like
communities I guess of moms right-wing
people usually call them out and call
them like Munchausen mommies which is
interesting but
it's unfortunately just becoming more
and more common as this gender ideology
becomes more and more common in society
wow
this is I can't believe this is real
yeah it's real life yeah unfortunately
um but he's gonna get through it I'm
Gonna Save him it's not gonna last
forever
so what now you're in court trying to so
you have 50 50 custody now yeah so what
happened is like I told you I moved to
the Bay Area I was rewarded 50 50
custody as well as amending his birth
certificate making his Lane made his
name have my last name which was I felt
really fortunate to win that and then
after that some safety concerns arose
things regarding police and CPS and some
other stuff and so I provided all that
to the court as well as this gender
stuff and false accusations against me
as I mentioned earlier that can be
grounds for custody
um and I provided all of that to the
court we had a five-day trial in San
Francisco family court and I felt great
about the trial you know we had an
extreme amount of evidence on our side
versus not very much evidence at all and
two months later we got the decision and
it was essentially that
custody would stay the same and that my
son would continue to go to the doctor
that he had been going to which I didn't
want because this doctor was like okay
with that sort of stuff
well and she testified in court as well
this doctor
and what'd she say
so she didn't make any comment on like
my son specifically but what she did say
which the court took her as like an
expert witness to this is that it's
basically okay or something like that to
treat a kid as if they're non-binary
which I radically disagree with
wow you know and just the fact that she
testified pretty much against me in
court like who would want to see a
doctor that did that to you
so you brought to court evidence that
she falsely accused you yeah right you
brought to court evidence that she was
trying to do this gender neutral type
non-binary stuff to your son yeah
um and on top of that you said there was
violence or something or some sort of
need to say violence you said something
else you brought to court too yeah there
was some there was a rest and stuff
involving her and my son as well as
something pertaining to the restraining
order I had and criminal charges because
of that being violated
um those two things as well and those
were much higher on the priority than
the other things you mentioned because
you know we know it's San Francisco so
but there was a lot to it it was like
850 pages of evidence and yeah the court
didn't rule on any of it to change
custody and how much have you spent
trying to get custody of your son
way too much
I've been fortunate enough that I've had
some pro bono attorneys help me as well
as paid some
I don't want to get specific but I've
spent most of the money I've ever made
and had my parents help me as well wow
and had the pro bono attorneys and here
I am now and I'm so thankful that my
gifts and go raise money
thank you to daily wire and everyone and
it's a really hard how much these
attorneys cost it's like it's like not
even fathomable if you work a normal job
and then see how much the attorneys make
because that's always what I get pushed
back like why don't men just fight for
their kids and it's really great to see
you do that you know but it's I talk to
men all the time that they just run out
of money
yeah I think that's a huge possibility
like I think you can represent yourself
I think it'd be pretty hard to go up
against attorney who knows all these
like loopholes and tricks and wording
things and try to trick you
I mean personally I would do that if I
had no other options for sure but it is
definitely a makes a wall like if you
can't afford an attorney that makes it
very hard to fight for custody
What legislation would you like to see
changed
I think that it should be completely
illegal to trans kids with hormone
blockers or surgeries sex change
surgeries I think perhaps even treating
them socially as something that they're
not I think maybe we could classify that
as like a form of abuse emotionally
I think that Dad should have a fair shot
same as the mom it should be like a
equal playing field for moms and dads
not moms having the advantage what do
you think about those hypothetical laws
I think those are good ideas but I
have men should be awarded custody
I'm a little sexist like more because
like no no I think men should well I
think if you look at the single mother
home stats and single father Homes
single father homes Fareway better
correct yeah like much better so I think
if we're doing the best interest of the
kids if that's what's important they
always say everyone should get custody
court always is best interest of the
child like I don't I don't think it's
about equality I think it's about what's
best for the children and so if fathers
are raising better kids why wouldn't we
give fathers custody right I'm I'm on
board with that why do you think there's
such a lack of like appreciation for
fathers today
I think it's just that narrative that
you brought up earlier that like there's
all these deadbeat dads and dads just
run away from the home and don't want to
be involved with the kids and then when
you start learning about it you're just
like no maybe he couldn't afford an
attorney or maybe right you know he did
everything he could and he was getting
to be his kid's Uncle seeing him once a
month and he had to live somewhere he
didn't want to live and all these things
added up that it just wasn't you know
worth it anymore which I can't really
comprehend because I would never give up
on Sawyer but I just think it's the
narrative yeah and it's it's in the
media too when you see like the
Simpsons like in all those like shows it
always shows the dad is like this idiot
this bumbling yeah you'll once you see
it you can't really unsee it like since
Family Guy yeah it's always the dad's
like this fat idiot and the mom has to
like run the house and nothing would get
done without them all and you think
that's like pushing a narrative onto US
yeah I mean I think it's part of the
like programming like where we say we
don't need fathers in the home right and
I think the fathers are so important
like as I was telling you earlier like I
think I would be a raging liberal if I
didn't have my dad and so it's like we
don't have
we act like we don't even need fathers
in society I think it's like a travesty
honestly I totally agree I mean like you
said the statistics with all the
homeless and crime it's heartbreaking
that we would do that to kids what if
you learned
um through this journey about like
parents all right so I'm assuming you
you've probably researched a lot into
this transitioning stuff like what have
you learned about like kids that
transition
I I see nowadays and I'm really glad I'm
starting to see this there's all these D
transitioners like Chloe Cole and all
these people who are speaking up and I
think it's really Brave of them and
awesome to see that because they tried
to push this narrative that it's like a
net benefit or like they'll blackmail
parents like oh your kid will kill you
themselves if you don't accept their
fake gender and it's like in reality
I've the stats I've seen are like a
slight increase in suicide or about the
same after they transition there was
some new studies out of Europe like
Finland UK
um and Sweden I believe showing some
like pretty bad statistics to going
along with
um the transgender ideology for kids and
transitioning them and they're starting
to slow down and walk it back which I
think is great but everyone needs to do
that yeah I mean I think it's child
abuse to be honest like it's so
confusing to the kid like I was a tomboy
growing up so it's like if my parents
pushed me that way I I certainly maybe I
would have did it you know
um because like when a kid you don't
know what's going on you're confused
totally yeah I'm glad your parents
didn't push that on you it's scary to
think no they're DieHard yeah that's
good yeah my parents would never buy
into that but yeah I mean I think people
are doing it for themselves more than
for the kids like they're doing it to be
get likes on social media and to oh I
never thought about to put hierarchy
like higher class right yeah so that's
at least what it seems like to me was
was she always a feminist
she was pretty left-wing yeah yeah yeah
I used to think like oh we could like
just put that kind of aside that stuff
now I think it's probably pretty
important to try to share values yeah
with someone you have kids with but you
know life's unpredictable and right I
tried to see the good in people and
stuff and yeah I was just I've talked to
some guys that said they're like their
girlfriend or whatever got into this
like group or something that sort of
influenced them but it seems like she's
always kind of been like that
yeah I mean it seems like it progressed
as Society did yeah as well like things
have just gotten crazier and crazier but
I I know there's like these groups of
moms that are all transiting their kids
and talking about it on Facebook and
stuff and it's definitely scary because
they encourage each other to do it more
and more and go further
explain yeah there's mothers groups that
all trans their kids or have non-binary
kids and talk about it and everything
what type of stuff do they say have you
looked at these groups I'm I haven't
spent much time researching the group
specifically but yeah
it's a scary thought for sure yeah
because I can't even imagine oh gosh
that's so crazy
well it's like seeing other people
online talk about it and you know be
encouraged about it it's gonna make more
of it right so in California you said
it's easier because it's just
interesting because it's very different
than the UK so in California it's easier
to get 50 50 custody well perhaps I
should be specific that San Francisco
Bay area is like pretty inclined to give
both parents split custody like 50 50.
although I'm sure that moms still win
custody much more like Nationwide it's
like 18 percent of dads when full
custody 27 don't even see their kids but
I just I talked to some dads in like
South Carolina and Texas and different
places and they said from talking to
them it seemed like they probably have a
harder shot getting custody in some of
the more conservative areas which is
surprising I'm just curious like what
your advice would be to get custody of
your kids because
um a lot of guys are just wondering how
they can actually get 50 50 custody
well I think for one just show the court
the effort you know move to where you
have to move file in court whatever you
got to do try to put the money together
find a pro bono attorney whatever you
have to do just show your kid because at
the end of the day too you want to be
able to show your kids this that you
fought for them you know you don't want
your kid wondering why'd my dad bail on
me you know right and you just have to
put the effort I think if you put the
effort maybe it'll be hard at first with
some false accusations or whatever
things happen but I think over time
those things don't last the court starts
to see the reality and the truth and
who's you know the one telling the truth
in these custody battles and I think
over time you'll eventually be able to
see your kids that's the other thing
they don't talk about is women telling
the kids that the dad's a deadbeat right
when really he's been like fighting to
get in their lives for years
yeah it's it's a scary thought I've I've
dealt with some negative things my son
told me that were said about me wow
we're sad for me to hear yeah but
but yeah and they realize like I always
say this like they realize what the moms
have done
at some point it might be when like you
saw it happen to Kanye in front of you
know our eyes he figured it out at like
40 right right but at some point the
kids aren't stupid they grow up and
figure out like what the parents have
done yeah I think so too I think the
truth just like I was saying about court
same with the kids themselves they'll
see it eventually so you just got to do
what's best and never give up
well I'm curious what you think about
like marriage I hear you talk about that
a lot oh my opinion on marriage yeah
well I hear you talk about it a lot and
I'm just interested in like the
statistics about like divorce and all
these different things oh um I think
that lib rules of ruined marriage I
think the marriage is it's not marriage
anymore do you know what I mean like
because tell me what you mean because
okay what is marriage when you look at
marriage vows it's like For Better or
For Worse for richer for poorer and
sickness and in health like there was
all these in-depth marriage vows right
and now you can get divorced for
anything right okay so no fault divorce
yeah which actually that might have been
a conservative I think that was that
right I'm not sure I don't know but but
it's like so marriage isn't marriage
when you can get divorced for anything
the whole point of getting married is
we're stuck in this right when you take
that out it's a lifelong commitment it's
not marriage so I like I think when
you're getting married and it's not
marriage like that's not marriage
anymore okay and so especially when it's
like 50 of marriages end in divorce
so and it's actually hired because
that's fifty percent of first marriages
second and third that's going to go up
to like 70 something percent so it's
actually more than 50. yeah I think I
think they've ruined the institution I
just think it doesn't exist like they're
because no matter what you do if you get
married in this country it is still
legal to have no fault divorce so all
you can do is pray to God that the woman
doesn't do it that's it like she will
always have the majority of the power in
the relationship a better chance with
the custody and everything is yeah which
is scary even in states with laws that
are more fair they can't undo Society
they can't undo conditioning right so I
think it's like
I think it's just unfortunate
um because there's people that really do
want to get married and have those
values but as women were crazy like
honestly one day we'll feel one thing
one day we'll feel another but we're not
supposed to have institutions that allow
us to do crazy things when we're feeling
crazy right so we're not supposed to
have laws that back us up in leaving and
divorcing over chores
he doesn't do the dishes let me get
divorced right but there's laws that say
that's perfectly okay and so because of
that it's not like what they're
describing it's not it's not marriage do
you think there could be like
for divorce you have to show and prove
something more legitimate would that be
a possible solution yeah I would prove
they cheated on you or whatever that's
what they used to do well I don't really
I have interesting opinions on cheating
too okay because because a lot of times
the girls will get married and then stop
having sex with their husband and then
he cheats it's like well you kind of did
that to yourself right so that's my only
I really think people should well work
out cheating if they can I really think
it's abuse and addiction and real abuse
not the abuse they have today where it's
like he didn't let me spend five
thousand dollars on the credit card
therefore I was coercively controlled
and financially the real abuse right
fine I'll let you leave over getting
your ass beat that's fine and maybe like
he's an alcoholic or a drug addict okay
you know that's not good for the kids
but outside of that and with the woman
too but outside of that like
I I think that mayor it's really sad
because I believe in marriage and I do
think like the institution the real
institution is a great thing but the way
it is today I just think it's not
marriage
I think that's a really good perspective
and I tend to agree with with what
you're saying I mean it's crazy because
girls do divorces or 75 of the time
right and 70 to 80 it's 90 if they have
a college degree interesting yeah
college degree I'm not surprised by that
yeah yeah because I mean the feminist
the ideology [__] they'll just throw in
that yeah more propaganda pushed on you
yeah that's for sure yeah it's it's a
crazy thing that we're just having like
these marriages that just keep ending
and then these kids with these single
parent homes we definitely have to
like you said put the best interest of
the child in well every every issue in
society is from single mother homes yeah
it's not single father because the stats
aren't the same like whoever you know
just that just a devil's advocate even
though I'd agree that they're just more
likely to be with the moms
um no I don't think so I think that yeah
I mean this is just my opinion yeah I
think that like kids need structure
right and like because women we're a bit
nuts like it doesn't matter I mean we
get on our period we start whining like
we used to he's like why is she mad and
then she's like oh
oh I just feel like I mean I'm sure
every guy's been in a relationship with
a girl and he doesn't even understand
what she's mad about we were fine last
week well we're hormonally different
every single day and and so I just think
kids need that structure of this is good
this is bad but with women we can't
offer that structure like we we have
that nurturing but I think for like
young kids like structure is more
important than nurturing that's just my
opinion that's I like that that's cool
because it routine structure is so
important for kids like me and Sawyer do
the exact same thing like in similar
ways and times and if like let's say my
mom's watching him she'll mention to me
how he'll he'll say like no that's not
how we do it you know like he wants to
do exactly how me and him always do
everything like the same time the same
way exactly yeah and women were just a
bit more chaotic like I just think like
men are structure women are chaos like
in general like
um you know and people think that's
sexist maybe it is but it's like if you
ever see single women like they used to
call into and Samuel's show and the
smoke alarm would always be ringing like
the oil like [__] like the the
oil change light on the car is always on
like oh look at we just like kind of
live in chaos a bit and you see the
women get nuttier and nuttier the older
they get when they're by themselves like
women aren't meant to lead families
that's not our role we're not supposed
to do that so when we have to lead a
family it's chaotic
and on top of that like you're bringing
strange men in and out to interact with
your kids and now the strange men have
more of an influence on your kid than
the dad who gets to see him like what
three days a month for like every other
weekend normally is like the go-to I'm
hearing that's crazy that you're hearing
that so often I'm extremely thankful to
have half custody at least for now yeah
I mean I can't imagine only seeing them
like just having them four days and him
being away for three I mean those three
days like I'm just I'm thinking about
him I'm missing him that alone's hard I
can't imagine going like week or two
weeks all the time without seeing them
and just wondering how they are and yeah
it sounds tough and that's what they
don't talk about like men want to be
involved in their kids lives like men
they I've had guys cry about try like I
want to be involved in my kids like all
I want to do is see my son and yet they
act like these men are just running
around deadbeat dads getting everyone
pregnant which is not true yeah into it
what I don't buy into it at all dad's
all the dads I know are extremely about
their kids lives want to be involved in
every way shape or form
I don't know how this is happening but
what percent how many judges did you
have on your case
just one or did they switch
they do switch routinely but for the
most part it's been won the whole time I
guess in the very very beginning it was
a judge and then it switched and then
now I believe it's switching again for
the first time but mostly it was the
same judge for this were they men or
women
it's been women yeah but I think the new
judge is a guy the guy it's pretty
interesting and there's appeal court too
and that's a separate thing the what I'm
doing an appeal right now of the
decision
um from the family court appeal Court's
like higher than them and you appeal and
I don't know who the judge will be on
that so how does it work so they made a
decision and then you appeal it and it
goes to a higher Court yeah you
basically get their reasoning for why
they made the decisions they did because
they do these findings of fact and they
have like numbers and they put all these
different things that they found and
then at the end they put an order of
custody and different things and you
just specifically challenge which things
and give you a reasoning and evidence as
to why you don't believe they made a
proper finding what's your experience
been like in the court like with the
judges do they typically do you think
they're biased do you think they're left
or no
I would say I think in San Francisco
it'd be more likely that people would
tend to be left-wing politically but
judges are supposed to leave their
politics at the door you know Justice is
supposed to be blind
and that's at least the ideal and I'd
hope that that's how it would be yeah I
think a lot of them are like feminists
to be honest a lot of like I found that
it's female judges a lot that are like
kind of indoctrinated in the same
feminist that in the UK I don't know
much about the U.S court system I'm like
new to but in the UK
um like a lot of them they attend these
liberal universities and they come into
um they come into the court system where
oh gosh I can't remember what it's
called but the way they're trained is uh
I cannot remember the name but it's
under like a feminist program okay so a
lot of them it's and it's the same way
they see abuse
it's through like a feminist lens where
they always look at the stronger person
as the abuser and that's how they're
literally like trained the Duluth model
that's what it's called the Duluth model
is what they use to train all police
officers and all judges and people yes
yeah you should look into it it's a job
that's really scary sounding yeah and it
was like it was implemented in I think
the 70s so you think that guys are are
more likely the abuser that's just a
narrative no I think women are more
likely to abuse I mean it depends like
what what is your bar for abuse we'll
say real abuse yeah right but I mean I
think women are more likely because I
think like you see it all the time girls
will like hit a dude right and and
semi-seriously right and okay maybe it
doesn't hurt him or whatever but like if
we're gonna make the bar hitting women
definitely do that [__] more like they
definitely do and I think men are kind
of embarrassed like no guy wants to go
the police right and say I'm getting
beat up by my chick that's embarrassing
for sure so I really think when it comes
to one well I won I think most abusive
relationships real ones they're doing it
to each other I think they're both
probably crazy they're both probably
toxic and there's studies that that say
this when it comes to one-sided abuse
that women hit men more than men hit
women the most abusive relationships are
both
that's really interesting yeah I mean
from my studies I've I've seen more that
women are more common to be the ones
actually abusing physically wow what
study are you talking about I don't
recall off the top of my head I have so
many different numbers in my brain for
all this custody stuff I study at once
but
I saw that what are the most like
damning numbers you've found from like
your custody research
I mean probably the ones we talked about
earlier just regarding like single
motherhood and then 90 of homelessness
and like 70 something percent of prison
inmates and all that I think that's the
biggest uh well and I've spoken to
freaking
um homeless like guys that run homeless
shelters and that's what they'll tell me
like the majority of the homeless are
from these like multi like these baby
mamas basically that had like three or
four different baby daddies and like
none of them in their lives and then
they got taken and like put into foster
care it's a real problem yeah it's
tragic I I think we have a serious
homeless problem it's scary yeah and
it's like okay you don't think that
maybe in those situations the men should
have custody when she's got four
different baby father I'm like are you
crazy yeah that seems like a good time
to think that the Dad should have
custody for sure four different dads
like if it was reversed yeah I don't
think the court would think you're a
very good person
if you had impregnated four different
women I think the court would by default
consider you a bad person but when it's
the other way they're just like oh let's
you know
yeah no it's a double standard it's such
a double standard it's like women can do
no wrong in this Society right and no
matter what they're the better parent
when it's like what evidence do we have
that that's true there's no evidence
yeah there's there's not I mean
thankfully we have the evidence that we
have now to show and hopefully we can
make some changes and have dads continue
to fight because
Society is not working having all these
problems I'm single and single
motherhood homes and divorce it's we
definitely have to do something to
change it
have you looked at all into excite
that's like my next thing I want to look
into like what would need to happen to
change the laws have you looked into
that at all like specifically like you
have like how to like get a bill in and
I'm not exactly sure but that's an
interesting thought because I think it
should be 50 50 across the board and
then when do you think it should go to
one parent or to the dad
well actually false accusations abuse
well you know honestly yeah I'm gonna go
the way I feel
I actually think that whoever leaves
so the others should get cut like
even if they're not married
or specifically I don't know I haven't
thought this through I I honestly I
think that Dad should have a little
sexist I think dads should get primary
custody just because the numbers say
they do better and I think you know if
we're gonna go for the equality thing
maybe 50 50 but I I don't know I just I
think we need to stop incentivizing
women to break up families I think
that's the biggest thing I think alimony
should be gone I think child support
should be gone I think all of these
rewards for women making bad decisions
just need to go immediately and I would
even go as far to say that maybe there
should be a consequence for her breaking
up the home
I could I could see that helping for
sure because it's it's definitely
incentivized and you can look at when it
started happening I think around like
the 60s right we put it in the welfare
state
and what's happened since then is
divorce single parent homes
kids decline
gender ideology all these things so I'd
be curious to see that happen too are
you on child support at all I'm not on
track there's no child support orders
right now okay 50 50. okay I was
wondering some people have 50 50 though
and one parent still pay his child
really that's that's what I was
wondering if it's 50 50 is it
automatically no child support yeah it's
not automatic that might be like what
they'd tend to go towards but basically
it's just on income regardless of the
custody
wow it's actually crazy to me that it
took you a year and a half to see your
son and there was no consequence yeah 15
months I mean like the most horrific 15
months of your life it's like a part of
you isn't there you know for no good
reason and you want nothing more than to
find that other part of you and you know
hold him see him be with them and you
didn't get to do that for 15 months and
that's just
not yeah no repercussion
that's so sad it's yeah it's sad
what
but we're like as close as ever yeah I
mean me and my son like
if you saw us it's like we're like the
closest like parent kid combo I've
honestly ever seen we're just
super tight what motivated you to like
keep going during that because I'd
imagine it has to be so frustrating like
spending all this money not knowing if
you're even gonna get custody at the end
it was never a thought in my mind to
give up I just
100 was all in from the beginning there
was never a second where I contemplated
running away I've had people I knew like
oh you should just give up you know
court all these things we're talking
about you could you'll have to be their
kid's uncle and pay all this child
support but I never considered it I was
always all in on being there for Sawyer
and when when he's older like you said
like I'll be able to look him in the
eyes and tell him that I did everything
I could there wasn't one more thing I
could have done for him you know
you any pictures I have lots of pictures
can I see well I don't have uh my phone
on me right now oh okay but I can show
you some after for sure yeah well I was
like I wanted to see him he's got like
nice curly hair it's pretty cool what
did the doctor say in court
um
she said that it was okay to treat kids
as non-binary as well as some things my
attorney got out of her on cross-exam
about
things that were said that weren't true
to the doctor
about me basically I won't go specific
but wow things like you know lies about
me false accusations we got the doctor
to admit those things were told to them
wow yeah
is family court public like can anyone
go watch a family court it's interesting
because if you have the login you could
watch on Zoom
um usually like if you tried to get
my court cases documents they would say
no it's private because it involves a
minor
um it seems like people can spectate to
an extent I mean if you're in a hearing
you're spectating other people as that
happened before you oh it'd be
interesting to like spend a day on
Family Court you could like watch it it
was interesting to see some I've seen
some stuff that really surprised me
before like what like and to be fair I
don't know all the details right so I'm
just going off the 15 minutes that I saw
but it blew my mind because I remember
there was a dad who essentially had just
sworn at his kid he caught his kid
watching an inappropriate movie
and swore at the kid
and that was it that I knew about
evidence wise and because of that he
hadn't seen the kid in a few weeks and
he was graced by the judge to get
granted like a day or two a week not
overnight after that and I was like
have you seen my case this is like how
is that even possible right yeah wow so
he swore at the kid and then they said
you can't again I don't know all the
details right that was all I that I
heard in court and I was really shocked
is this common
yeah it's it's definitely common that
you know anything that Dad does gets
used against them you know I think I
think when moms start
considering the custody stuff they're
probably trying to even sometimes
um and I'm sure dads do it as well but
like trap the other parent you know try
to trick them into saying something like
something like that I saw an interesting
video like Stephen Crowder
and his wife having an argument and I
don't know the context you know so I
thought that was interesting to get put
out online without context well yeah and
I'm like that sounded bad but really I
didn't I was like yeah so no I'm like
that's abuse you can't use the car
oh that's a low bar right well they'd
say it's like worse because she's like
pregnant and you don't have any context
and he kind of like yells okay it makes
him at least appear as the bad guy no I
saw that clip I was I kind of thought
she planned dicks it was from 44 years
ago so I'm like yeah okay so now she's
giving you this clip and dude is acting
weird like as a girl I'm just watching
this and I'm like why are you
but like you're saying this abusive
behave like I'm like this is this seems
like what I was saying like a trying to
bait him yeah and I'm just thinking like
but because you can't use the car and he
asked you to walk the dogs
this is I'm like okay he said he doesn't
love you I'm like oh come on we've all
said crazy things that you don't
relationships during a fight he does
during if I'm like can we stop acting
like we all have these like clean
relationships that are just like you've
never said it like she didn't say
anything crazy back to him but it's like
we live in this Society where if a guy
does anything wrong in a relationship
it's abusive it's coercive control it's
Financial control when it's like no
maybe he just was a dick that day you
know it happens like and I'm sure she
was a [__] a different day like people
can make mistakes in relationships and
not be bad parents I absolutely and not
have to lose custody like there is I I
think there's very few reasons that it
uh that
that a father should not have custody of
his kids like I even even if he is say
abusive or on drugs I don't see like why
can't he have supervised custody like
like you go have you you guys go see
your baby daddies in jail for God knows
what like you can go do a supervised
visit with him but the kid can't have a
supervised visit with his father that's
an interesting point yeah it's like what
if it's supervised we get a cop there or
whatever like why can't they see them
it's a really good point and regarding
like the fighting in relationships like
I come from a big family four kids my
mom and dad are still together which is
amazing and we've all had fights before
but we're all still a family and we
still all love each other no matter what
like I've we've all done things we
regret and said things we didn't mean
but it's like we're still a family it
doesn't have to be the end of the world
and I think when you put something
personal online it just kind of says
something about you know what I mean
because it's like you're trying to be
the victim when you're trying to win in
the court of public opinion right when
at the end of the day is that good for
the child like Hillary like genuinely
for the Hillary is that good for your
kid to have this like clip of you like
calling the dad an abuser right but when
you know damn well that I he could be
but I don't think so yeah I mean I don't
particularly think so either it's
interesting like you say stuff online
that that went back to my case
um I told you like false allegations
against me so a lot of that was posted
to social media like so the day I won
half custody of Sawyer right one of the
greatest days of my life
um my son's mom called me an r word on
social media and called the judge a liar
I have this picture he's presented to
the court wow and
so that was you know there was a and
there's way more examples that was just
a good one but that was part of the
grounds for my restraining order well
and like what consequence does she have
for that like this is the problem we're
going to get into as women we start
calling everything great I'm gonna say
grape just for YouTube but we're gonna
we're gonna call everything grape like
we're losing the meaning of it how can
you be in a relationship with somebody
that graped you totally because if if
someone great for me in a relationship
I'm going to the police so it doesn't
make sense that now the the you were
fine with him when you guys were
together a year or two later when he's
trying to get custody all of a sudden
now he's a grapes yeah it's just like
like this shouldn't even stand in court
in any way like this should be such a
joke and a laughing stop guilty until
proven innocent somewhat in family court
and that's what people don't realize
like how
unfair family court is because it's
based on a balance of probabilities it's
not based on evidence
and I think you probably are familiar
with this at least it's in the UK I'm
not as familiar with the us but in the
UK it's like so and I've been told it's
the same here it's based on
um a balance of probability so it's more
likely that he did it than didn't do it
interesting so it's not based on
innocent until proven guilty therefore
they can throw in all of these abuse
allegations and if enough stack up
because in the UK too what they'll do is
they'll have
six like reasons like there's six forms
of abuse Financial abuse coercive
control
um great like the physical like there's
a whole thing right and basically if he
meets like four of them so maybe he
didn't let you spend the credit card one
day he made you not wear I think they
even have to provide proof of these
things or just you claim it correct they
claim it and I've had like guys show me
pictures of a screenshot of a girl
trying to get the guy to hit her
like trying to provoke him to hit her so
they could go to court and get custody
of the kids that's how like manipulative
some of these women are it's crazy yeah
one of the things I provided the court
was like our text messages from the time
we were dating right as well as like her
first or Facebook whatever social media
posts where she would say like you're so
amazing blah blah blah right I love you
so much all these things I showed that
to the court like does that seem like we
were in any sort of abusive relationship
right like and I felt that I pretty well
dispelled that and the court did find
that I'm not a Grapist yeah to be clear
that's part of the order did she take
down the post or no
I don't know oh you don't know because
I'm probably but okay because I'm just
thinking there's no consequence for
girls going online and accusing men of
things and ruining their entire
reputation I think and it doesn't have
to be girls but I think false
accusations generally like that should
be a crime yeah like a serious one too
like because if you accuse someone of
something serious
besides definition it's like it's way
beyond that when you're talking about
kids and everything that goes beyond
just your reputation that's like your
life your your life your kids you know
the most important thing to you
what do you think of these like
feminists that are saying that it's in
your your kids best interest to come to
his own and
basically pick his gender on his own I
think that's delusional if I let's give
an example that's not about gender if I
was to ask my son
what he wants to eat all day every day
he would just eat ice cream and candy
and that's it but would that be the best
thing for him no because we all
acknowledge that kids don't always know
what's best for them that's why they
have parents to guide them
um and they could go further than that
like you know you could think he's
Spider-Man but you're not going to be
like okay let's go to the tallest
building in town and we pretend we're
Spider-Man all the time and it's fun and
I love being silly with them it's like
the greatest thing ever but you'd never
do that no so why is that the one
exception if your daughter has anorexia
or anyone in your family you don't
you're like yeah you're right you don't
have to eat dinner tonight or what if I
came home and I said Mom I'm black they
would have a field day you're insane
they're not doing this
but they they feed into like kids I mean
like every kid's a little delusional you
know what I mean because they're kids
like they're fun they believe in Santa
right right but we don't well with Santa
we do a bit but for the most part for
them to feed into like they're you know
you don't tell them this is and in a
certain age you tell them Santa isn't
real or less yeah I would feel bad
saying this in case a kid's watching but
you know but it's like
there's no criminal offense for that you
know yeah but perhaps there should be I
think there's I think it's abuse and
it's really confusing and now you're
having these kids like come out later
and say oh no I was really young and
impressionable right and I now I've
chopped off my parts and my voice is
different and this is this is what my
parents have led me to I think we should
hold the doctors and parents accountable
they should at least be open to
litigation at the very least if not
criminal charges once we I mean I know
you can't like retroactively
do things like criminal charges but we
should establish some new laws for that
sort of thing because I agree that
that's at least something that appears
to be abuse in my opinion as well yeah
what do you think about them basically
saying that this is like misogyny a
patriarchy
you men and that men are just abusing
power
them just being like the narrative that
we hear all the time and social media
yeah
movies I think it's not true at all I
mean the example is we've been giving
like girls have more power in marriages
and family court so that's just one
aspect where that's not true but I don't
believe there's like some cabal of guys
trying to oppress women by any means and
I think most guys
care deeply for women and respect them
like in their own way and
I think it's not a healthy idea to put
in people's brains
yeah I think it's
women whining honestly I think it's
women whining and just saying oh my life
is so hard because I'm a girl but
usually they're just kind of lazy and
usually fat
yeah that's that's my opinion on it you
know but
it just goes to show that it's like if
if men had all this power and patriarchy
like why don't why don't you have
custody all the time yeah why don't you
have your son when that's the what is
more influential than the Next
Generation
that's why the most important thing to
me is protecting children correct and so
like it's like what
if we wanted to influence Society how do
you do that kids because that's the Next
Generation who is influencing the kids
the women mostly because most women lead
relationships in my opinion because if
you guys are in a contract right me and
you're in a contract and I gain
everything from leaving and you lose
everything right you're going to always
be trying to make me happy right so like
I I think that the way that the laws are
set up
what do you think about the phrase happy
wife happy life I feel like I always
hear that women oh my God because we're
never happy have you ever really tried
to make a woman happy I I feel that I've
made women happy but who knows but it's
like okay if
and so it's like
if you try to make like try to make a
girl happy on her period trying to make
a girl like we're emotion that's okay
like we're meant to be emotional and I
think it's a superpower that women have
in all honesty like the way we can use
it for good right because we can like be
so comforting and we can really make
people feel like heard and we can't like
there are jobs that women do that like
men just cannot do the same but I think
we also have to look at like we are so
emotional and our feelings change every
day and if his goal in life is to make
you happy you're never going to be happy
because women don't like men that just
bend into the will of whatever they want
we don't like men like that's
fascinating while you're trying to
debate them to doing that but you also
don't want them to do that no I mean
like testing them have you ever seen a
guy that gives up everything for his
girl no totally like yeah women hate
them like it happens so often like
especially when guys first fall in love
with the first girl they fall in love
with you lose your friend for like a
year right in high school or whatever
because you'll just do everything for
them because it's like yeah
she always dumps him I mean I think it's
incredible some people are like high
school sweethearts but for the most part
yeah like and so it's like yeah like the
girl will dump him if he tries to make
her happy so it's like what
it should be a healthy balance of like
being yourself doing your own thing and
as well as also making sacrifices for
each other I would think or hope
just that's it
yeah because I think women are happier
when we're trying we're like trying to
make the man happy and like follow his
lead like I don't think women want to
equally lead the relationship I'm not
saying that her happiness isn't
important like it like we want to be
happy but it's like happiness shouldn't
be the goal of a relationship that like
that should not be a goal like the goal
is to raise your kids and I think that
kids are raised in the best environment
when the woman respects the man's
leadership that's just my opinion I
really I really like what you said like
the especially the part like Jordan
Peterson talks about this a lot um you
know like when people you ask them what
they want to do and they'll say like oh
be happy it's like life isn't just
happiness there's going to be so many
ups and downs no matter what no matter
how amazing your life is tragedy is
going to come you know so I agree that
happiness being a goal isn't the best
idea and relationships should be no
different
bill of goods that we should get
everything in the relationship like we
should he should be tall handsome
successful and on top make you happy all
the time and if you're not happy you can
leave and divorce over chores over
chores yes yeah there's some big content
creation what do you think sold to guys
then just that you should make them
happy yeah I think men are like told
that what do you think about Valentine's
Day then
oh my God it's like about women it's
like a perfect holiday like I thought
you might say that yeah I mean
cute like I mean it's nothing wrong like
I love love so it's like if you want to
do something on Valentine's Day that's
adorable okay go do that but again I
think it's it's never about like what is
he like it's always the man doing
something for the girl and never the
girl you're definitely the one who buys
flowers and chocolate yeah like what did
the guys get sex they're like I get this
anyway
like what like what what presents have
really gotten in General on Valentine's
Day right I don't yeah I can't even
think of too much it might get you a
little uh something if they're
particularly nice girl for sure yeah but
um it's definitely more about the girls
on that day yeah
but it's crazy so I'm curious so you
said Tim pool donated money to this like
how did that come up
um well daily wire broke my story I'm
extremely thankful to them and it's
funny because I watched him pull often
and one morning I just woke up and it
was like I had an email that someone had
donated to my gifts and go and it was
Tim Poole and it was ten thousand
dollars I was like this is the craziest
thing ever is this real life Wow and it
was and thank you to Tim Poole it's
really kind of him how did the daily
wire get in contact with you
I I reached out to them and they had
married talk to me and screened me and
me and her spent a lot of time talking
and going over evidence and stuff and
they wrote a written article yeah yeah
okay and how like did that blow up or
how did that what happened yeah well
like Matt Walsh retweeted it so a lot of
people saw it and that was when Tim pool
it was a few days like it wasn't like
the day it came out but yeah Temple did
it a few days later or something and
I've been extremely blessed ever since
both the financing as well as just being
able to speak to people like you and you
know just tell the truth and try to
stand up for kids as well as dads
what effect do you think this has on
children
I think it's just damaging them long
term and it's confusing them short term
I I don't see
any positives of
treating kids as something they're not I
think we should want people to be happy
with who they are I think that's better
way to live
I wonder I see it more of them like to
making men into women than women to men
in the trans this is just what I've seen
this is anecdotal so I wonder if it's
like feminist like hatred for men that
when they have male Sons they kind of
try to make them women it's fascinating
I mean for I know it's more common for
moms
um to be the one participating in you
know transiting their kid or treating
them as non-binary I I think there's a
huge Skyrocket right now
um
like Abigail schreier's book
irreversible damage of teenage girls
doing this transgender thing I don't
know if the parents are involved or not
and that
the numbers are just shooting way way up
but as far as
moms go I don't I don't know the numbers
as opposed to boys and you know girls
sons and daughters but that's an
interesting thought and I wouldn't be
surprised especially when you bring up
things like spotting the husband or
something like that
do you think she did this despite you or
because she believes it
I don't know what she does sort of
things
no idea
I mean I I can hypothesize but perhaps
it has something to do with me yeah for
sure or at least a part of it but I
think maybe she believes the stuff I
mean she's doing it herself right yeah
yeah I'm I'm sorry this happened to you
this is like I can't even this stuff is
crazy I appreciate it yeah it's we need
to we need to stand up for kids and stop
it yeah and I think it's it hurts the
children at the end of the day
especially with the stuff in sports have
you seen that oh it's insane when
they're putting men in women's sports
completely needs to get banned for All
Sports there's a reason we have separate
spaces I think it's insane they're good
and even if you let them which let's
just say hypothetically which you
absolutely shouldn't but let's just say
you did still make them change in the
guy's locker room at least like have
some respect that way like have you seen
Riley Gaines yeah about the swimming oh
she's great she's amazing she's amazing
but it's like you put him let them
undress in front of the women that's
insane even if you believed that that
they could switch their gender you still
wouldn't do that to people there's a
reason we have separate locker rooms and
they're doing in prisons too and prisons
oh I identify as this and they like
happen to be like a rapist that then of
women and then they're they're believed
that and put them in a women's prison I
think that is like I don't I fail to
understand how we even debate some of
these things like that's so crazy it
should just be absolutely no way right
away to both those things and children
as well but yeah the and you're an
athlete right girl so what what do you
think about I think it's it's disgusting
have you had to compete ever no I've
never competed against what I wish they
would I wish I would say no no I mean I
was just a volleyball I would just be
the biggest Menace okay to whatever
organization tried I swear like I I'm
like I'm filming everything right like
I'm like I wish I would just be the
wrong [__] I'd be like Riley Gaines but
like on steroids with with the following
you know what I mean how she's so loud I
would live stream it I would bring in I
would bring in I would get all my fans
to come in and come to the game and like
boo yeah I would I would just be an
absolute Menace like they they couldn't
do that too I would
but no it's it's sad because it's the
it's going to be the end of women's
sports if they keep allowing this how am
I supposed to compete like my brothers
okay my older brother his name is Austin
he freaking
how do you say
he competed in soccer until he was like
15 but he's really not an athlete right
I mean he doesn't train like that I've
lifted for like 10 years okay since I
was 16. I'm 26 now okay he's stronger
than he could still out bench me and he
doesn't lift ever you know what's super
interesting you bring up the lifting
thing I was at my high school that I
went to I want to say last week
and they have this thing on the wall
about the lifting weight records and
they have boys and girls separated
and I took a picture of it and I
remember thinking like wow just this
board on its own dispels the men and
women sports thing entirely because the
guy is like what comes to mind was like
bench press was I want to say two and a
half times what the girls was that you
know it was it was unfathomable higher
not double more than double you've seen
the one with the braces
where they had men and women race
against each other like they did this
couple I mean running so they did this
co-ad like like sprinting team and the
freaking
um basically at the end the they had one
team had all the guys go first and the
girl go with the end and they were way
ahead like the girls were so far ahead
of them and she got laughed
the guys all came in and they just beat
her yeah like there's nothing you can do
and it's so and I play I've played
against guys before uh just on my own
like at parks or something okay but I
played like two years of college
basketball and I know if a guy made it
to high school basketball most likely
he's gonna win unless he was absolute
trash like I'm like and that's an extra
I don't know 50 70 18 19 20 7 years or
six seven years of training that I had
it's a long time yeah and so it's like
if you get guys with even close to the
amount of training I've had they're
gonna they're gonna beat me and that's
what you saw with the swimmer the
swimmer he's breaking but they're not
just beating them they're breaking
records they're taking scholarships I
mean it's like it's devastating the fact
that um correct me if I'm wrong but some
of the people that are supporting this
call themselves feminist and I'm like
how this is the most anti-woman thing I
have ever seen in my life and you know
my least favorite ones are the guys that
the the girls that support it when they
were ex-athletes so you don't have to
compete anymore you're done you're done
and now it's like now your opinion is
put them in the sports when it's like
you know how much you loved it you know
how fun it was like you know how great
women's sports is in general like do you
know how hard you have to work to be a
female athlete there's no payout there's
nothing at the end of it there's no fans
there's nothing there's not like NFL NBA
we make millions of dollars yeah there's
literally nothing at the end so if you
become like a elite women's athlete
you're literally playing because you
love it and these women that played in
high school will say oh well I was an
athlete and I support this they piss me
off the most because they're done so
it's like me I'm done so should I go and
say oh the next round of 6 16 15 year
old girls they should compete like it's
so disgusting I can't even believe this
is like legal I think it's a lot easier
to support it when you're not the one
doing it but yeah yeah so it's like
these girls are getting like hit in the
face did you see the anime fighter I
want to say it was Fallon Fox oh it
fractured a girl's gold and the
surgeries and the sir and they're
transitioning younger and younger and
the surgeries are getting better and
better where I can't some of these girls
look like like girls
it's crazy I saw this girl on a modeling
on a magazine I didn't even know she was
a he
because they're they're and it's crazy
and there's a lot of Health
complications that come from
transitioning kids and they don't talk
about it they don't you're a lifelong
patient
like it's not like you just stay the way
like so you're referring to people that
had a really successful
uh transition physically
um but they have to still continue to
take their hormones
and stuff or it won't stay that way your
body's constantly trying to put you back
to who you are yeah and they can't have
like normal sex ever because if they
like chop like you like I don't even
like thinking about it's like how is
that even like doctors are supposed to
do no harm
um and how we're considering this
to fall in line with that like they're
doing harm we know that objectively you
know it's it's heartbreaking
yeah and
it's to look at numbers like what are
the outcomes for them
I don't know the exact numbers but I'm
just glad to start seeing G
transitioners like Chloe Cole and stuff
speak up I think it's really important
yeah like we need more of it and I think
if we can get the legal process started
to make it illegal
lawsuits against doctors and parents as
well yeah the doctors should be in jail
any doctor that
takes seriously transitioning a kid I
want to like do a documentary where we
send a kid into one of these just to
expose
like undercover yeah I wanted to yeah
because just
or I was thinking about like going in
and saying myself like oh I'm thinking
of this and saying I'm depressed and
just see how quick they give you
hormones how quick yeah because it needs
to be exposed I've heard a lot of
stories of like one or two times that
was it and they're ready to give them
and sometimes one just ready to give
them testosterone or whatever yeah I
didn't see like the video at this just
people the transitioners claiming that
but
yeah well it should be extreme well I
think it should be illegal me too but if
it's legal it should be the extreme case
we go through everything and I I spoke
to a hormone doctor about this
interesting a lot of times they find out
their hormones are off
so like there's a lot of I couldn't
figure out why are there so many
lesbians in basketball
and it turns out playing competitive
Sports raises girls testosterone levels
oh okay so a lot of times you'll find we
have deeper voices a lot of times like
we will display certain traits that are
a little bit more masculine because our
testosterone is is elevated
and a lot of times these people that
think they're the opposite gender it's
actually a hormone imbalance where they
have like five times the amount of
estrogen or or um whatever it's called
testosterone yeah yeah testosterone as
the other gender and so what this guy
was doing before even all this stuff
became mainstream
like I'm talking like 20 years ago 30
years ago he would talk to these people
that wanted to be the opposite gender
and fix their hormones and they didn't
want to anymore wow and a lot of times
the doctors will do tests and they won't
even make they won't even
check they don't even do a hormone test
yeah I don't it's definitely something
we have to try to fix yeah and it's it's
taking advantage of emotionally like
vulnerable people for sure yeah like
children and just you know depressed
people anxious people I mean I think
that the feminist ideology just
depresses people together I talked to a
girl um Annabella Rockwell I was on her
podcast she was incredible um she used
to be a leftist and she said when she
was in that it happened at College of
course that she had you know depression
and those sorts of things and I found
that really fascinating and it's also
crazy just like how much of that there
is in society in general now I mean I
saw a study that majority of kids in
college had mental illness problems and
that adolescence it's like 40 something
percent and it was just really shocking
and the men have low testosterone like
it's way lower than Generations ago
right no liberal men have lower liberal
versus yeah yeah they have lower testost
but also just like our generation
compared to like correct yeah correct
lower as well yeah well they tell them
like big
they feminize men from a young age I
think it's like even when you're talking
about the therapy stuff like it all the
fat like all of the therapists are
indoctrinated with feminist [__] I'm in
the school now for psychology it was I
didn't really need I kind of I dropped
out but I was in it and um for my
masters and like
it's all feminist [__] all of it
okay and so it's like these guys will go
to
therapy and they're told to emote like
women
like they're telling the men to like be
with women yeah yeah they're like oh
talk about your problems like women like
when they say oh why don't you
communicate better like be more upfront
with your remote like all this little
[__] it's like that's how girls
communicate guys go fight each other
yeah
they don't gotta talk about [__] they'll
get into a [__] some guys fight because
it's fun but they say that's wrong
that's bad when it's like why are we
teaching men to be women but it's like
mostly teachers that are women in these
institutions and mostly T like
therapists are mostly women too so it's
like yeah we're teaching men to be women
no wonder they have low testosterone
yeah I mean when I was growing up me and
my friends would wrestle and box each
other all the time that was like part of
what we did for fun that's how you guys
deal with problem yeah yeah and then
people have fights at school and like
depending on the situation of course
there's somewhere it's like pretty
serious but usually like you guys will
be kind of like more cool after you guys
fight each other you like have a certain
respect for each other afterwards it's
really interesting I've noticed that I
don't get it at all because of like
women it's probably just a guy who it is
because if women fire it like we never
will talk again like we hate each other
for life but if men fight it's like
they're like it's weird they're friends
after yeah it's it's not that uncommon
for them to be friends after I have a
few guys I was in fights with in high
school or middle school and we talk now
and it's no big deal yeah what do you
what do you say
um but what what message do you want to
get out there about this whole thing
the most important message is always be
brave for sure but I think that children
are the most wonderful innocent
magnificent things in society they're
the future like you were saying earlier
they're they're who's going to be next
deciding everything and we just need to
protect them at all costs and then my
secondary message would be dads are an
extremely important part of kids lives
and we need to make sure that dogs are
fighting for their kids and have a fair
shot in court
well thank you so much for coming
up thank you I really appreciate it it's
very nice to meet you too it's been
awesome guys make sure you like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell um
and where can they if they want to
support you in court or anything do you
have like I have a gifts and go at
saving Sawyer if you search me on social
media it's Harrison Tinsley on
everything okay okay great follow him
guys
Channel and I'll talk to
talk time